[Musica]
Allora
In principio era il verbo lo so come
titolo può sembrare impegnativo e forse
l'avete già sentito qualche parte un
qualche cosa vede orecchiato in effetti
è uno straordinario claim direbbe
ripubblicare cioè uno slogan soltanto
che è stato scritto nel primo secolo
dopo Cristo da Giovanni l'evangelista
e Giovanni con le parole ci sapeva
proprio fare pensata l'apocalisse ma io
devo parlare del potere della parola e
quindi mi serviva un incipit letterario
potente l'imbarazzo della scelta era
amplissima immaginate migliaia di anni
di letteratura c'era che ne so
chiamatemi Ismaele Moby Dick merrà
Melville bellissimo però mi avrebbe
costretto a parlare di capodogli non so
quanto vi sarebbe interessato e forse
non era del tutto a fuoco
e poi c'era quest'altro che era
veramente meraviglioso
molti anni dopo il colonnello Aureliano
bondia di fronte a Crotone di esecuzione
si ricordò di quando il padre lo portò
per la prima volta a vedere il ghiaccio
Gabriel Garcia Marquez Cent'anni di
solitudine però era lungo e quindi l'ho
scartato e quindi In principio era il
verbo ha sbagliato la concorrenza
vorrei cominciare però con un piccolo
test alzi la mano Chissà che cos'è
l'osso ioide
non vale per i medici
e i Biologi loro dovrebbero saperlo e se
non lo stanno Facciamo che il nostro
piccolo segreto rimane tra di noi allora
per chi come me tirano molto tempo fa ne
ignorava l'esistenza Ecco lo presento
Beh in effetti non ci dice un granché un
osticino però mi farebbe impazzire nel
puzzle del nostro scheletro perché è
l'unico osso che non è collegato ad
altre ossa e alla fine della lingua
dietro la nostra carotide e quelle
quattro antennine o corna Come vengono
chiamate più tecnicamente sono collegate
un complesso sistema di muscoli di
cartilagini che sovrintendono al nostro
apparato respiratorio impediscono che ci
strozziamo trattenete il fiato chiudete
la gola Ecco loro hanno fatto il loro
lavoro l'evoluzione ha fatto il suo
lavoro però poi in Sapiens ci ha messo
del suo il Sapiens Sì noi
la storia parte qualche centinaio di
migliaia di anni fa con un secondo un
copione che forse abbiamo già sentito il
Sapiens da Buon ultimo decide di
lasciare l'Africa perché a scarsità di
risorse
e prima di lui in eurasia dove si stava
spostando C'erano stati gli ergaster i
denisova e poi i nostri cugini
Eccoli i Neanderthal Da notare noi rami
neri e lo erano i bianchi comunque
queste rilevante Beh come potete vedere
Forse non era una buona idea litigare
con Neanderthal era molto più grosso di
noi molto più muscoloso e la scatola
cranica fa pensare che fosse più
intelligente allora come abbiamo fatto a
soppiantarli la risposta in quel piccolo
osso perché noi abbiamo trasformato quel
complesso apparato di muscoli e
cartilagini e uno strumento per la
fonazione le corde vocali
anche il Neanderthal ce l'aveva però
avevano sviluppato quindi parlava Ma noi
avevamo molte più parole parlammo di più
meglio Con più precisione e fu così che
li guidammo la pratica Neanderthal ci
mettiamo qualche centinaio di migliaia
di anni ma si sono estinti e Il passo
successivo per essere davvero
straordinario perché prima in modo
macchinoso poi sempre più logico
intuitivo inventiamo la scrittura ed è
qua che facciamo veramente il botto
passatemi il termine perché non solo
riusciamo a trasmettere le informazioni
Ma la comunicazione più non è più
lineare nel presente riusciamo a
tramandare con il passato le nostre
informazioni le nostre scoperte le
nostre storie e riusciamo Grazie alla
nostra capacità di immaginazione anche
immaginarci il futuro
Ecco adesso facciamo un altro salto che
è difficile che è difficile da come dire
che è difficile datare
dopo la scrittura noi arriviamo a
internet e poi le grandi autostrade
informatiche Baricco come vedete ha
scritto un importante saggio che si
chiama the game e fa un osservazione
abbastanza intelligente Fra le tante e
dice le autostrade informatiche sono
state inventate da ingegneri maschi
Bianchi occidentali e per fini di lucro
è arrivato il momento che vengano anche
le donne I letterati di altre culture di
etnie e bisogna essere ottimisti Perché
in effetti se guardate le rotte dei
Navigatori Beh sono state tracciate da
Cristoforo Colombo Giovanni Caboto
Amerigo Vespucci Insomma tutti i maschi
Bianchi occidentali molti mostri della
motivazione veramente pieghe pensate a
Cristoforo Colombo che ha concluso le
sue le sue i suoi giorni in carcere era
troppo perfino per l'epoca
però la parola è come un virus lo Si
cantava negli anni 80 che se lo ricorda
lorienderson la lingua giseless loro
hanno aperto il mondo la nostra lingua a
contagiato ed è stata contagiata e si è
evoluta secondo uno come dire un copione
che purtroppo abbiamo imparato il virus
si evolve Ma in questo caso
positivamente però tende presente che la
parola non crea solo mondi li spiega li
piega li Domina li sovverte Ma la
mancanza di parola questi mondi li può
distruggere penso ancora delle parole di
odio
pensate in questo momento quanto la
guerra si stia affacciando ai nostri
confini no
e la guerra Noi pensiamo di risolvere
con le armi mentre invece l'unica
soluzione naturale della guerra è il
confronto e il dialogo cioè le parole
non bisogna andare molto lontane per la
storia per vedere quanto in effetti
l'assenza di parole possa aver provocato
dei danni ecco vedete questi sono
soldati americani
andiamo in Afghanistan dopo vent'anni
noi Dopo miliardi di dollari spesi dopo
decine di migliaia di morti e questa è
la cosa più grave abbiamo lasciato il
paese perché
Perché i talebani hanno opposto una
fiera Resistenza
i talebani vetrina dominante sono
pashtun la parola indoeuropea dice
proprio quello che sono pastori ma sono
anche guerrieri E per loro la guerra fa
parte della vita ma anche la sconfitta
che non è disonorevole a condizione che
ci si sieda un tavolo e se negozi nei
termini della resa noi questo non lo
facemmo
e come temo lo stesso errore in Iraq
perché la storia insegna ma a volte noi
ci dimentichiamo di imparare Dopo una
facile Vittoria
affrontiamo una devastante resistenze
irachene al triangolo sunnita Ve lo
ricordate un incubo per i cronisti di
guerra
anche in quel caso il mucabarat che era
il temibile apparato di sicurezza di
Saddam Hussein attendeva generale
americani per discutere i termini della
transizione e anche lacci rifiutano di
parlarci
e poi ci fu la rivolta irachena ma
d'altronde anche la guerra fredda ha
seguito un copione simile non ci fu mai
uno sconto diretto fra nato e Patto di
Varsavia fu una guerra basta intensità e
si concluse con il collasso dell'Unione
Sovietica Anzi più correttamente Con
l'inclusione Secondo molti storici è
proprio quello questa mancata
discussione questa mancata trattato di
pace che fu siglato l'origine delle
crisi attuali che stiamo vivendo però
adesso voglio proporvi Come si dice una
small picture e cioè due storie La prima
è a Gazza 2007 riesco a entrare
nonostante stia vivendo il momento più
terribile un embargo devastante che sta
colpendorale palestinese Nulla e nessuno
può entrare uscire da quel posto Io però
riesco a entrarci perché sono un
giornalista e riesco ad avere un
appuntamento con un portavoce di una
delle Milizie più temute
si presenta come aboomhammer
cioè un soprannome che vuol dire
praticamente Mario Rossi e quindi è
legittimo sospettare che non fosse il
suo vero nome
e io avevo paura devo dirvelo perché
pensavo di trovarmi di fronte un pazzo
Sanguinario crudele invece si presentò
un omino mite un padre affettuoso ci
ricevette a casa sua giocava con i suoi
bambini Scherzo era una persona
ragionevole poi all'improvviso dovremmo
passare l'intervista si indossò la
mimetica si mise e passamontagna in
braccio il kalashnikov e scioglierò
l'ennesima invettiva antisionista io ero
spaesato
e si scusa fermo un attimo ma tu
parleresti mai con israeliano e lui no
mai E questa assenza di parole che rende
le posizioni inconciliabili ma voglio
raccontarvi una storia invece di segno
opposto
Tel Aviv
Eccola questa aiaon Street invaso da
centinaia di migliaia di persone da
febbraio di quest'anno diventa
l'epicentro della protesta contro la
riforma della Giustizia
centinaia di migliaia forse milioni di
persone sotto la bandiera con la stella
di Davide protestano contro la riforma
della Giustizia voluta da beneamen
netariau il premier eletto da poco il
quale appunto propone questa riforma
viene considerata antidemocratica e per
cui milioni di persone scendono in
piazza ed è impressionante vedere come a
fianco ai colorati militanti lgbtq ci
siano anche i veterani con le loro
lugubri magliette nere che inneggiano il
sacrificio di Masada oppure le
femministe a fianco agli imprenditori ai
Tech gli ortodossi i coloni vicino ai
filo palestinesi tutti insieme uniti per
un'unica istanza e Tutto questo grazie
al Tam Tam dei social che gli ha
permesso di far avvicinare delle
posizioni che a volte sono
oggettivamente incompatibili Ecco io
voglio dire questo
Immagino che se abbummo Ahmed o o come
si chiama si togliesse da solo mimetica
si togliesse il suo passamontagna
togliesse il suo Kalashnikov e facessero
lo stesso anche il veterano delle guerre
che ne so dello Young pour
Io credo che uscirebbero a parlarsi a
parlarsi davvero a comprendersi perché
la parte più difficile è sconfiggere le
parole di odio che hanno avvelenato le
loro reciproche esistenze
pensate a quanto in questo momento la
pace sembri lontana
l'Ucraina e perfino il tentativo di Papa
Francesco abbia cozzato contro la
chiusura di zelinski e lo ostinato
silenzio di Putin loro non si parlano
non si vogliono parlare non si
riconoscono come interlocutori e questo
il problema principale
noi quando parliamo della guerra diciamo
la parola passa alle armi ma ci
dimentichiamo un dato Ovvio banale
scontato le armi non parlano
Non a caso noi Invochiamo il Messaggeri
di pace e vogliamo che il nemico
incontra il nemico in quello che è la
conclusione naturale della guerra i
colloqui di pace
Ora però
un momento non vorrei che voi passaste
che io sono il classico inviato di
guerra che viene qua a raccontarvi delle
banalità del tipo Fate l'amore non fate
la guerra cioè l'amore fatelo non è
quello il problema ma non è risolutivo
mettete i fiori nei cannoni La guerra è
brutta questo lo sappiamo
la faccenda Purtroppo io ho imparato sul
campo sulla mia vita sulla mia
esperienza con la mia professione che è
molto più complicata
lo ricordate E stai pensando a sconfitto
il Neanderthal grazie alla sua parola
grazie alla sua capacità certo non
perché è più forte certo non perché più
intelligente ma lo ha combattuto perché
la guerra fa parte dell'umanità fin dai
suoi albori e noi
siamo il risultato noi il nostro
Progresso il nostro sviluppo siamo
risultato della fine di ogni conflitto
ed è per questo
che io dico che bisogna ritornare
dall'inizio bisogna ridare il potere
alla parola far tacere le armi perché
In principio era il verbo da qui siamo
partiti ed è qui che dobbiamo tornare
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]